is the best game alert hey Jackie Nina
that is so bright out that evan has to
wear sunglasses that's qro and so dark
we're doing
good morning Wow is it still morning
look at the time 1131 I stayed up really
late last night I got inspired by an
idea and was up until two in the morning
working on it and eating it was very
patient with me we love me that she's
very special let's flash me here no why
flash what that's your face let's see I
thought you miss up together where is
your mind crash holy cow we didn't have
to wake up early which is nice Nina
still woke up when did you wake up i
woke up at eight woke up at eight I
heard something I don't remember when I
caught up it was nine so it was seven
hours it's not bad that's not bad it's
nice to wake up when the Sun is up
anyway so today we're going shopping
we're gonna find Nina some new clothes
would it take Nina we're gonna find
something henan fingers cross fingers
cross fingers and toes crossed I don't
think your toes can kinda cross my toes
yeah okay careful you're driving right
whoa okay new clothes hanging out at two
o'clock I'm also meeting up with a
YouTube friend of mine Adam we've never
met in person just connected online so
that'll be fun we have the starbucks
Haven how you feeling today feel a
little bit better okay so off to the
first series of malls here we get some
food
and that's it so we were driving by and
we saw the dennys and realize think we
have and have a Denny's yet cuz row is
rushing in the morning to get the Disney
World so Nina really wanted to have a
Denny's so we're going to go and eat
some 1130 breakfast Hayden is busy
trying to find 10 differences between
two pictures are you doing you got to
find 10 keep going what's Nina gonna eat
or semi
up to me what do you want pizza now we r
get something a little healthier here's
my strategy I always look for favorites
so anything with a bell on it says is a
must-have fan favorite so I'm gonna see
if I can order off the senior mention
because I like this senior scrambled
eggs cheddar breakfast okay now we got
to pick something for Hayden well
Hayden's menus only lunch stuff so I'm
gonna get this humongous lumberjack slam
on there looking to split so will you
just have a little bit Nina wants to
finish off finding the differences Nina
this is the kids menu and the kids
activity guide you know that right here
comes the food you ready mr. you ready
you get nothing at nothing all right
yummy oh and the pancakes wow thank you
okay we finally made it here she getting
her wasn't that bad to finding parking
was insane there's a hundred and eighty
stores here outlet malls and people are
going crazy parking the parking up on
the grass they're fighting each other
for spots and we drove all the way
around and finally got a spot so I'm
happy Kaden this here in his stroller
ready to go have some fun I Nina's ready
to go get some amazing clothes what are
we hoping to find friends just called
let me lock the car Oh where's the key I
found the key momentary freakout this is
Nina what are we hoping the fine tops
shorts pants dresses bathing suits oh
very sad shoes belts earrings underwear
you wonder what here we go oh I got one
for you here you go we are only one
store in the Nina already has a purchase
all right just leaving the store Nina's
happy with her new purchase her shoes
way to go it's boarded 22 and I'm
supposed to be meeting Adam at two so we
got to find starbucks and go meet with
them all right so I'm here with Adam IV
we're at the starbucks chillin with our
caramel cappuccinos Adam help tell the
viewers what your channel is all about
my current youtube channel I have a lot
of music parodies on their kind of
switching gears into more of the music
gear reviews
like how to set up a home studio how to
do video editing how did that stuff i'm
still gonna do comedy videos but yeah
europe grow and that so I posted on
Facebook that I was coming to disney or
at Disney and a new said are you in
orlando let's meet up yeah I didn't know
you from Orlando looks at work how do we
first connect I didn't remember I think
we might have been commenting on the
same video that Tim Schmoyer day was
that it i think so ok you'll create this
video ok ok and then I checked out your
channel like what you were doing
subscribe that we've been kind of going
back to fourth yeah okay okay yeah I i
just did a guest video with him I saw
that like a week ago make it two weeks
ago it went live like oh no that was
what their dearly release was a week ago
to yeah I was like maybe three months
ago I subscribed though I'm on all into
half good I know I got a feature I gotta
get feed you getting it on there man you
got to share the stories one one person
at a time yeah actually when the Darra
leave saying drop that was I was it was
like a couple days ago and i'm at the my
Airbnb place and responding the comment
is ridiculous yeah I gotta go to bed and
the comments keep coming in I like
respond that every time with the hidden
panel has grown so fast over the I mean
he does amazing amazing videos quality
work very consistent yeah Justin see is
king on youtube yeah and that's why my
channel hasn't grown very much but ya
know it's tough awesome now you've been
dropping some hints I've seen recently
saying hey I'm doing something new
something big something exciting yeah
are you willing to it was sneak peek of
what's happening we're gonna it would
take way too long to do on the blog but
we'll have to do another video we'll
have to do a video collab toronto to
orlando okay when it drops is dropping
next month excellent ok cool oh ok ok a
lot of work I'm excited absolutely I've
been feeling like the drops you've been
putting out something's coming and i'm
waiting for it you're building the
excitement I'm not too planned or not
but I'm I'm waiting either I'll have a
new business or I'll die cuz it's been
there you go look at that that's some
passion okay we're going to enjoy our
drinks talk some biz and we'll see you
soon so while I was in my meeting with
Adam Nina went shopping and in my
meeting cost me michael kors purse so
Nina's in there right now buying it Adam
nothing expensive about meeting girl
thank you but it was fun what do you
think about Nina's new purse guys huh
two stores who went in together and two
things we've bought already this could
be an expensive day
nina is now dress shopping how about
these okay so we just came out of the
guests factory star I Nina after trying
on all those things but
she brought the brown pants happy next
up is Victoria's Secret Nina's gonna
check out some stuff and you guys are
not allowed to see not bringing the
camera just I guess banana republic all
right we are done shopping it is 623 are
you feeling mr. bad yeah Hayden feel a
little sick I'm shouldn't feel a little
sick my throat's kind of scratch a
little bit hey still agree Nina's okay
we bought some stuff successful day
we're gonna go home we supposed to be
home between five and six and it's
already six-thirty we haven't left yet
so we're gonna go and hopefully so
traffic good morning good morning it is
our last full day here in Florida last
night I was up late again I was up to me
I went about almost two oh my god I got
inspired I got inspired i was working on
something yeah I'm excited big things
coming we'll see I'm not ready to
announce anything yet but but coming
soon and then I was the first one to get
up that was insane I run eight eight
eight o'clock ish I got up and you
should Hayden's on 57 but he was in bed
Nina slept in but we have good news hey
then what's your good news I can walk
all of a sudden hate it as magically
better you can walk and run now we're
all very excited we are off to the
baseball game so this is my day yes Evan
gets a day whoo yeah so we get to go to
part of why I come down now is we've
spring training for baseball Blue Jays
are gonna win everything this year very
exciting so we're gonna watch a game I'm
a little sad that it's a split-squad I
didn't realize so half the team is here
and half the team is playing somewhere
else so we were going to drive about an
hour and a half yes a little bit more an
hour and 45 minutes to get to Dunedin
Florida maybe pick up a copy on the way
yeah yes and that's our last day before
we have to wake up tomorrow early anyway
Nina's looking cute in her blue jay
outfit well that's it it's ten-thirty
we're off to a good start and go jays go
we are in a lot of traffic and I'm not
happy and I feel like we were in traffic
last year last year we got there just
after it started and I was super sick oh
my god i'm kind of sick not to what's
happening
it's not great okay don't get sick don't
get sick don't get sick I brought you
some lemon water got stuff to do live to
change people to help and it's daddy's
day can't be sick on Daddy's Day and the
traffic is looking better okay good go
go go here we go so we found the first
starbucks in miles and decided to stop
but made us late so Evan got a venti
caramel frappe mmm me and he got me hey
would you get me all right is it
surprise it's a venti caramel macchiato
oh and then Gator got a special water
now we're very late and we need to
awesome everybody everybody close your
eyes for the next hour here we go so
we've been stuck in this traffic for a
while now and we're supposed to get
there now as the game is starting so we
are now officially late and we just
discovered that is because there's some
accident here and everybody slowing down
the watch this motorcycle that got hit
by this car Wow
it's pretty bad so we're gonna be late o
wise and we're low on gas great yeah all
right we made it in we we had to deal
with Hayden need to go to the bathroom
I'm going to get food and I seem to get
gas but we parked we are 40 minutes late
so we're so we're late but we're gonna
go in Tina's got her hat on oh and your
shirt ever match the fuse and Here We Go
Go juice go next time mental note leave
early
you
a shoulder is the best game alert hey
Jackie Nina Nina's other guy take game
take me up to the cloud buy me some
peanuts and cracker jacks I don't care
if I never get back in war room for the
it's a shame also a videographer his
videos he was nervous Nina's nervous
she's praying just praying here praying
to the baseball gods side
Nina's shock we lost mr.
get in the car might the child let's
make our way home so it's eight o'clock
and just passed and hidden need to get
ready for bed he's in his pajamas and
already had his bath and everything and
had to make one last video for today
because christina my video editor showed
one of our videos to her kids he has two
sons who saw Hayden's Darth Vader
toothbrush and they became obsessed with
it and they they wanted to have their
own dark theatre toothbrush so we went
back to the store and they were all sold
out of the dark pewter toothbrush we got
to obi-wan Kenobi toothbrushes the good
guy want legs up like set the show
pretty cool right pretty cool I see mine
with sears powerful so we're going to
send these to Christina's boys but first
what I want you to do we're going to
make a card for them from Hayden card
because you found these ok so make it
hard for them so tell me what this is
yeah that's me and that's true disease
boys this means perfect you want to hold
it up and smile so tomorrow we have to
wake up super early I think around five
thirty to get to the airport and return
our car and do all that fun stuff catch
our flight to go home so hidden you get
to sleep and we're going to pack up
ready to go and we're coming home to end
city Toronto here we come
good morning it is what time is it 601
Nina kinda has shaky hands from all the
alcohol she consumed last night uh-huh I
know oh god it is so bright out that
evan has to wear sunglasses that's jus
rol dark we're doing oh so oh I don't
know what I'm doing you know you get all
this stuff uh it's early yeah we have to
leave at eight and it's 60 we got to
take the car back we gotta get some guys
we gotta do everything ready and uh yeah
ok let's go quickly through what our
favorite part of the trip was for
everybody ok ok you're to paper two
segments and show that training ok i
think the favorite part is
the sun thurs rise Oh Big Thunder
Mountain yeah big thunder mountain and
this place actually this place is really
big I'm gonna go with spending time with
my family I'm gonna focus on driving get
us there and get on the airplane and go
home to to run all right we made it we
took the car back it took forever but we
made it we're going to be boarding in
about 15 minutes Angela again I didn't
have to go through the insecurities of
the trash pick up my shoes do not lean
law charity any time with my five toe
shoes and I'm gonna go find us some
coffee and some breakfast and then we're
gonna get on the plane and come home so
I made it home uh it's nighttime and we
haven't filmed anything since we left
basically got on the airplane and just
started to crash hard from the lack of
sleep but then I got nauseous in the
plane and anyway we weren't in the best
of moods i was feeling sick and so we
didn't film anything we came home and
and nacked immediately fell asleep and
then we went shopping and we got some
food and is making some smoothies are
you putting chia seeds in there I gained
a bit of weight from those from those
daily frappuccinos in ice cream I see
yeah we didn't talk with the ice cream
and this dear
so you only want beer anyway timing how
they tend to get back to our regular
life and what what else we want to see
me with some weight yeah dancing again
anyway so thank you for joining us on
our trip hopefully it was like the video
hopefully you enjoy the video we will be
back on a regular schedule now that i'm
home and can start filming again so back
to the entrepreneur advice and wisdom
for the next couple weeks and that's it
believe we'll see you soon bye
you